americans racing to arm themselves while
crime surges across the country the fbi
running nearly 190 000 background checks
on black friday alone that's way up from
last year and perhaps this could be why
smash and grab rampages not just
happening in california but breaking out
all across the country in places like
new york chicago and minnesota it's
forcing some stores to beef up security
and it's causing some people just decide
maybe they shouldn't go shopping just
buy it online greg black friday more
like
we'll be glock
back
i said i said this a million times gun
control is dead and it was killed by the
leftists and the media they killed it by
pushing riots as protests and pushing
the defending and the demoralization of
law enforcement all that's left is the
second amendment and it's dawning on
everyone like a giant red nuclear pill
that it was detonated over america that
the only thing between you and anarchy
is self-protection the problem with the
democrats and it's a problem in every
facet of life from immigration to
self-protection they don't understand
human nature and the incentivization of
human nature they have been
incentivizing gun purchases by
decriminalizing crime and putting the
criminal on a pedestal while putting
victims in jeopardy no cash bail means
that if you call the cops because you
were assaulted that guy's going to be
out and now he's going to be pissed off
because you called and he's going to be
out if he's in your neighborhood you're
screwed your only recourse is to protect
yourself this is why you can no longer
crack down on legal guns because it's
going to be a war because you know what
it's the it's the lawful citizen who's
armed
so that is actually another interesting
point geraldo that about just the
support
so some people used to say like the nra
was the worst thing possible thing but
now there's all these new gun owners
that are law abiding gun owners they
went through the background check got
their gun the biggest job of government
is to keep citizens safe and if there's
a feeling of insecurity then people are
taking it into their own hands that's
why they're buying these weapons i think
that uh bail reform
as uh will join defund the police as
among the most failed
public slogans in modern political
history it's horrible uh you know i've
said it many many times look at chicago
look at philadelphia now 506 deaths in
the city city of brotherly love new york
hundreds my little town of cleveland
almost approaching 200. it's uh it is
appalling there is a ghetto civil war we
have to recognize it uh anarchy rules
when you can loot uh a luxury store or a
walmart uh with 30 strong 40 strong 50
strong why isn't someone taking the
license plate numbers of all of the
people uh who were participating these
aren't random acts these are these are
criminal conspiracies these are you know
also because they blocked out their
license plates well some of them did but
they there there must be a way when 40
cars show up to identify them this one
has a bump in the left fender this one
it takes a little more detective work
perhaps if they're covering their
license plates but you can identify you
can track them down you can't treat them
as organized with rico statues as
organized criminal enterprises and show
that the government has some balls they
use uh temporary paper plates that are
felt that are fake that's where they
just tear them off but they don't have
what you said cojones in your native
language geraldo they don't have that
because joe biden this summer announced
this big anti-gun trafficking task force
did they make one big bust they have not
made one big bust right and i found out
the only bus they made trump initiated
the sting two years ago so they actually
took credit for the bus trump did as the
statistician on the fire
you found some interesting information
okay when i say we i mean johnny found
as gun ownership grows gun homicides go
down exactly because you don't usually
mess with someone that is probably armed
and that's why you see a lot of gun
homicides happen in urban america
because they have such strict gun
control measures it's very hard for her
to get a legal gun the only people that
have the guns are the felons and to your
point you can
use weapons and then you can then get
arrested and liberal da's will not
prosecute for instance in chicago big
bloody weekend 52 shot little while back
10 dead they arrested 19 gang bangers in
this gang sweep almost all of them had
prior gun charges on them and the next
day 11 out of the 19 we're back walking
around on the streets so you can talk
tough about you know i'm gonna get tough
on guns they never get tough
but where is stop and frisk where are
police roadblocks where are these
obvious steps
necessary remember
called racist yeah i mean emily so from
the prosecutor's standpoint uh and the
pullback by police the prosecutors
wanting no cash bail or not even
prosecuting the crimes um
there's going to be a recall of gascone
in los angeles
and that could that could actually send
shockwaves if it were to succeed yeah
and chisa boudin as well the district
attorney in san francisco that's up on
the recall ballot in june it's because
the american people got duped when they
vote for criminal justice reform what
they think might lead to criminal
justice reform in instead they got
ushered in these radical progressive
left absolutely ridiculous prosecutors
who don't even deserve to be called
prosecutors
who absolutely dropped the ball but
let's take san francisco for a second so
they defunded their police they've
absolutely
emasculated all types of law enforcement
there they refused to prosecute anything
crime has skyrocketed livelihoods have
been destroyed and now a san francisco
supervisor has proposed oh we're going
to make it easier for businesses to hire
sheriffs armed and also in their uniform
but paid for by the business and it's on
off-duty hours so when you said the
biggest role a government plays is
keeping its citizens safe exactly that's
what our taxes pay for but there in san
francisco where taxes are sky high there
residents pay to be safe and yet the
city lets them down in that regard and
so retail business owners have to pay
twice for the same law enforcement
officers to stand and be potentially
killed in the line of duty like law
enforcement officer nishida who was
gunned down during one of those lootings
which we can't say because it's racist
because he was protecting ironically a
news crew in oakland that same media
that fails to call this for what it is
it's an abomination hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else